want to thank all the white people in
bridgeport for coming to the show
all right she's going to be annoying
[Music]
while you're turning things off can you
turn those guys off they won't shut the
[ __ ]
up half of them
why
should just kick her out
i completely agree but that's uh
apparently up to the club and uh i don't
know what they're doing but
try to get this show right back on the
road
it feels like someone said the n-word at
the tyler perry movie
all right i'm just trying to go back to
my swastikas here
[Applause]
[Music]
daddy norman
that was terrifying
what happened the rehab center to a
field trip what's going on
i realized oh wait a minute i'm not a
serial killer
[Applause]
we're all the same color on the inside
[Music]
[Applause]
now you're flicking me off what the hell
what'd i do
i don't know you
what is going on with this
crappy night
phone call
urgent phone call you flipped me off
what the hell
what's that a phone call wreck i'm from
hold on everybody the phone's ringing
[Applause]
you guys are great thanks for coming out
[Applause]